[Música]
según la organización Panamericana de la
salud el riesgo de brote de enfermedades
prevenibles por vacunación en las
Américas alcanzó su nivel más alto en 30
años el informe destaca que si bien
fueron la primera Región del mundo en
eliminar enfermedades como la
poliomielitis los programas de
inmunización han sufrido numerosos
reveses en la última década para hablar
de este tema saludamos a Ilan shafiro Él
es director de asuntos médicos y
corresponsal en jefe de altamed y médico
especializado en salud pública señor
shapiro Bienvenido a directo a América
somos conscientes que durante la
pandemia de Kobe 19 los esfuerzos se
volcaron hacia la vacunación para
prevenir este virus Pero qué tanto tuvo
que ver esta pandemia y Cuáles han sido
otras principales razones que han
derivado en esta situación que hoy
reporta la Ops
Antes que nada Muchísimas gracias por la
invitación me duelen el alma poder que
platicar de esto
Y en este momento tenemos que volver a
luchar con cosas que antes no teníamos
la parte de la desinformación y mis
información como se dice en inglés esos
actores que realmente están utilizando
la excusa de las vacunas del Coby 19
para sembrar dudas en las vacunas nos
están realmente robando vida al momento
que hemos visto que hemos podido salvar
y proteger millones de personas con la
vacunación y mucho de los niños en este
momento no conocen el polio no conocen
realmente lo que es lo que es el
sarampión y otras enfermedades más y
ahorita ya estamos viendo brotes y
problemas que antes no habíamos
ahora sigue la desinformación y los
mitos sobre la vacunación siendo un
problema en los esfuerzos para combatir
estas enfermedades
desgraciadamente Sí porque se sembró la
duda y el momento que se sobra se
asombra la duda y las personas realmente
Al momento de tomar la decisión de
vacunarse a ellos mismos o a sus seres
queridos Pues dice mejor me espero mejor
me mejor hago algo alternativo mejor
muevo otra cosa más y desgraciadamente
estamos dejando abierta las puertas a
tantas enfermedades que se puedan volver
a cultivar y muy importante afectar a
todas las nuevas generaciones Cuáles son
esas enfermedades que a las que usted se
refiere doctor estamos hablando de la
tos ferina Esa es la bacteria de
pertussis estamos hablando también muy
importantemente la parte del sarampión
estamos abriendo la puerta a otras
enfermedades Y también con las cosas que
ya tenemos como la vacuna de la
influenza Eso lo único que está causando
Es que de la misma manera que si
tuviéramos un barco Y empezamos a hacer
un hoyito pues entra la gota y no pasa
nada pero si tenemos muchas muchas Hoyos
y se están inundando por adentro del
barco se puede hundir
ahora qué se puede hacer o qué se está
haciendo para abordar estos desafíos que
mencionábamos anteriormente
la primera parte es la parte de la
información tener conversaciones y le
invito a cada una de las personas que
estén dudando que tengan preguntas que
se acerquen a su médico de esa manera
podemos compartir con ustedes la parte
de la ciencia Qué está pasando y
realmente la eficacia y seguridad que
estas vacunas están teniendo la segunda
es realmente hay muchas información en
internet pero parte de ella puede ser
utilizada de una manera extraña o mala
entonces hay que tener cuidado con toda
la parte que estamos consumiendo en en
instagram en Facebook y muy importante
esas cadenas de WhatsApp y la tercera es
que ante la duda mejor preguntar usted
mencionaba hace un momento enfermedades
que han experimentado Un aumento de
casos en los últimos años el sarampión
por ejemplo Cuál es su gravedad en
términos de salud pública
pasa un par de cosas número uno si si
una mamá le da sarampión al momento que
el niño está creciendo está embarazada
esto puede crearle problemas al al bebé
crónicos neurológicos y prácticamente
pruebas en corazón y es una vida mucho
más difícil y puede llevarlo hasta la
muerte la segunda es que las personas
que tienen por ejemplo que cáncer y que
no tienen inmunidad Si todos nosotros no
nos estamos protegiendo le abrimos la
puerta para que ese sarampión pueda
brincar a pacientes vulnerables y a
niños chiquitos entonces realmente lo
hacemos para nosotros y también a ese
momento creamos esa Barrera inmunológica
entre todos para poder ser mejor aparte
de los niños que usted mencionaba hace
un momento y de personas con este tipo
de enfermedades qué otra población se ha
visto más expuesta o se ve más expuesta
a este tipo de enfermedades prevenibles
todas las personas que están teniendo
problemas crónicos desde diabéticos
personas que han tenido cáncer problemas
inmunológicos sus defensas no funcionan
de una mejor manera y de hecho su cuerpo
se le olvida cómo defenderse contra
estas enfermedades Aunque hayan sido
vacunados la única manera de poderlos
ayudar Es que si nosotros eliminamos y
mínimo protegemos y ponemos Barreras y
esas barreras somos nosotros mismos por
medio de las vacunas nosotros podemos
ayudar esas personas vulnerables que su
cuerpo no está funcionando de una manera
tan eficiente para que sean protegidas
bien Ahora doctor Qué estrategias han
demostrado ser efectivas en la región y
que se puede mejorar para prevenir estas
enfermedades
de las cosas que más me gustan es la
interacción entre expertos y realmente
los pacientes los papás porque de esa
manera nosotros en un foro que no sea
médico podemos platicar mucho más a
fondo de los miedos de los mitos y
muchas veces realmente Están preocupados
por si hay efectos secundarios y ese
tipo de cosas al momento que tenemos un
contacto humano uno uno eso ayudado
muchísimo y la segunda parte es estar
realmente vacunando a la comunidad por
medio de de mensajes y conversaciones en
medios sociales esto ha ayudado
muchísimo para poder crear esa vía Y
tratar de contrarrestar Aunque es muy
difícil Toda la desinformación que
existe en medios sociales general el
doctor Ilan Zafiro director de asuntos
médicos y corresponsal en jefe de alta
Met y médico especializado en salud
pública para hablar sobre estos riesgos
de enfermedades prevenibles por
vacunación en las Américas que según un
reporte de la Ups alcanzó su nivel más
alto en 30 años Muchas gracias por
acompañarnos por el análisis aquí en
directo América un gusto como siempre
[Música]